AMY COBLE
AN APOLOGY TONIGHT FROM A MUSLIM
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE FOR WHAT
CRITICS CALL ANTI-SEMITIC
STATEMENTS.
IT CAME AS A CONGRESS WOMAN
RECEIVED CONDEMNATION FROM BOTH
PARTIES.
CORRESPONDENT DOUG McKAY
ALWAYS SHOWS US TONIGHT.
>> REPRESENTED REPRE
>> REPRESENTED REPRT
>> REPRESENTED REPRV
>> REPRESENTED REPRE
>> REPRESENTED REPRJ
>> REPRESENTED REPRH
>> REPRESENTED REPRN
>> REPRESENTED REPRO
>> REPRESENTED REPRA
>> REPRESENTED REPRR
WE HAVE TO BE WILLING TO STEP
BACK AND THINK THROUGH
CRITICISM.
THAT'S WHY I UNEQUIVOCALLY
APOLOGIZE.
IT STEMS FROM HER SUNDAY NIGHT
WITH THAT CRITICS SAY WERE
LOADED OF STEREOTYPES ABOUT JEWS
AND MONEY.
WHEN A FOLLOWER AS WHO'S PAYING
AMERICAN POLITICIANS TO SUPPORT
ISRAEL, SHE RESPONDED A PACK.
FREQUENTLY ACCUSED
CALLED OMAR'S TWEETS DEEPLY
OFFENSIVE AND DEMANDED SHE
RIPOLL IS
APOLOGIZE.
>> WHEN YOU TRY TO CULTIVATE
GROUPS ON THE BASIS OF RACE OR
RELIGION OR CULTURE, YOU ARE
GOING TO RUN INTO THE CONFLICTS
AMONGST THOSE GROUPS ON THE
BASIS OF RELIGION, CULTURE, AND
HEREDITY.
>> IN A LETTER CRITICIZING OMAR,
JERROLD NADLER ALSO ACCUSED HER
G.O.P. CRITICS OF ADVANCING
THEIR AGENDA BY DISTRACTING
THOSE COMMITTED TO EQUALITY AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
RECENTLY, DNC CHAIRMAN TOM PEREZ
ONLY OFFERED THE MILDEST OF
REBUKES OF OMAR.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, OR
PLATFORM HAS BEEN CLEAR ABOUT
ISRAEL, VERY CLEAR ABOUT DIGNITY
FOR BOTH ISRAEL AND THE
PALESTINIAN PEOPLE.
>> IN A RECENT TALK AT THE
CENTER OF AMERICAN PROGRESS,
OMAR SAID POWER WORKS BOTH WAYS.
>> YOU CANNOT STAND FOR FREEDOM
WHILE USE OF A TENTATIVELY
THREATENED TO PEOPLE FROM AN
ENTIRE RELIGION FROM ENTERING
THIS COUNTRY.
>> AFTER OMAR'S APOLOGY, SHE
ADDED THIS, AND I QUOTE.
AT THE SAME TIME, I REAFFIRM THE
PROBLEMATIC ROLE OF LOBBYIST IN
OUR POLITICS, WHETHER IT BE A